لا اعلم لا اعرف ولكن ربما نحن تغطيه ربنا
نايف نحن
نضطر ان نصمت الان طلب منا ان نصمت نشاهد
الان يعني اعتقد انه هذا غطاء حتى يعني لا
تعلم يعني كيف وضع المصاب وللمصاب حرمه
يعني فلذلك
اعتقد انه غطاء حتى يبدو انهم يقتربون
كثيرا نحن صحيح تم اخراج الطفله عائشه في
هذه اللحظه امامنا الان انا اشاهدها امامي
اذا عائشه الطفله عائشه تم اخراجها الان
العربيه ترصد لحظه انقاذ الطفله
الطفله عائشه انا اشاهدها معك غسان لكن
هناك التفاف كبير نعم صحيح اشاهدها الان
تم انقاذها اذن خرجت بعد ثلاث ساعات من
محاولات الانقاذ خرجت وهي بصحه ربما ان
شاء الله في هذه سوف تشاهد الان بعد سته
ايام عاشتها تحت الانقاض يعني وتم اخراج
حتى اخواتها من المكان اليك الصوره والصوت
ايضا
نعم نايف لكن طلبوا منا ان نصمت يعني لكن
عائشه عائشه الان نايف الحمد لله عائشه
خرجت من فم الموت
عائشه
واولاده قيصريه نايف